hello and welcome to the back for blood
pvp
showcase if you don't already know back
for blood is an upcoming four player
co-op
zombie shooter made by the creators of
left for dead
today we're diving deeper into the new
pvp mode called swarm
how it works and what you'll be doing
maybe even a little bit of strategy
we'll also talk with turtle rock's lead
game designer on back for blood brandon
yanez
to help piece it all together before we
get there though let's start off with
the reveal of a brand new pvp trailer
and
see what it's like in action
[Applause]
that's one down
[Music]
this is what happens when you don't
stick together
keep pushing them back
[Music]
forever
thank you
yes
that looked intense so there you have it
guys back for blood's pvp mode swarm
to hear more about it and to take a deep
dive into the gameplay
and the mechanics we have turtle rocks
lead game designer i'm back for blood
brandon giannis brandon uh can you tell
us a little bit about the inspiration of
this new pvp mode and what makes it fun
and unique
of course so just like our previous
titles we really enjoy bringing new
ideas to the table
while retaining the spirit of the genre
that we're working in so back for
blood's pvp is heavily inspired by our
previous titles it makes survival
fast action massive monsters and a touch
of horror so our goal
is to make a balanced and fun pvp mode
with just as much replayability as the
main campaign
so what's the structure of the pvp like
uh do you play in rounds
uh can you play as both cleaners and
ridden in one match or
are we swapping between the two yeah so
it's played as a best of three match
teams of four take turns swapping
between the ridden and cleaner players
the job of the cleaners is to scavenge
supplies
find a good place on the map to fortify
the position and try to last as long as
they can
the ridden's main objective is to kill
the cleaners as fast as they can
so this is achieved by choosing the
right ridden to counter the other team's
strategy
using mutation upgrades and by
coordinating attacks with other ais and
players
as the round progresses the swarm moves
in so this increases the size of the
ridden attacks and shrinks the playable
space
sometimes forcing the cleaners out of
their favorable positions right
so when a cleaner team is wiped from the
field the points are scored for how long
they survive
then both teams swap and then they go at
it from the other side the team that
runs the clock the longest
as the cleaners is the winner now i
understand you can play as
all the different cleaners in both co-op
and pvp
do you have a favorite character that
you play at so i have a couple
i play mom a lot she's a badass with
sawed-off shotgun she adds a lot of
survivability to the team
she can also instantly help teammates
that have fallen
during battle all of our cleaners have
special perks so that one is hers
let's jump into another trailer that
goes a little more in depth on the
ridden's progression through pvp check
it out
[Music]
intentional discharge
ah
damn it
what's up
okay so brandon we just saw that each
different ridden um
has their own variants as well as their
own mutations on each variant so can you
expand a little more on these special
abilities and how they work
sure so at the start of each round
players can choose between nine playable
ridden
each with their own unique abilities so
for example the stalker can pounce a
player and pull them away from their
team
or an exploder can time their detonation
in the middle of a group of cleaners and
fling them all in separate directions
now knowing that each ridden has these
different abilities how do they change
and improve throughout a match and
improve the riddance chance of winning
so as the written battle against the
cleaners they gain points
they can spend these points on team wide
upgrades called mutations
mutations upgrade and improve a lot of
different things on the written
side from adding effects to their
abilities they might buff the
common ai waves in size and strength so
the really cool thing
is so they affect the whole team and
they persist between rounds so
as a written team starts to coordinate
their upgrades things can get pretty
wild
what are some strategies that the rhythm
team can take on in order to get a leg
up on the competition
if the cleaners are really sticking
together you can swap to the wretch
and vomit on their location that's going
to cause them to spread out right
this is going to open up a whole bunch
of opportunities for your other ridden
players to attack right
so if you get them to spread out and
there's stalker nearby
stock will use the chaos to grab one of
the cleaners and drag them off into the
swarm
the wretches vomit also slows their
victims so if a tall boy who's naturally
pretty slow
can attack one of those slow characters
they're going to really be able to pump
them
another good one is if an exploder waits
for
a cleaner to go revive their friend they
can use that as an opportunity to
charge in and detonate on them sending
them flying and doing a massive amount
of damage
sounds pretty brutal so with that being
said which is your favorite ridden to
play out
that has to be the tall boy it's pretty
easy to pick up and play
and have a lot of fun hitting cleaners
across the map speaking of fun
let's talk about weapons now throughout
the trailers
you can see a number of different
weapons can you go a little deeper into
what those weapons are and how they work
so uh we really wanted to expand on the
amount of choices the player had
in back for blood with their weapon so
of course there's handguns
shotguns lmgs uh smg's sniper rifles and
a whole bunch of other types of weapons
each with sort of like a unique
character feel to them
now how deep does this weapon
customization go i really want to know
what are some of the different
attachments and options and how do they
change the gameplay overall
absolutely so there's a lot of different
customization options for your weapons
so throughout the world you can find
scopes silencers stocks
sites all that good stuff you can mix
and match them so there's a ton of
options
last question do you have a favorite
type of weapon absolutely so as i said
earlier
i really really enjoy playing mom so her
shotgun is definitely at the top of my
list ah that's a solid choice
all right we've learned a little bit
about how it all works the cleaners the
ridden the mutations as well as how the
customization works for the weapons
thank you so much for joining me brandon
and for giving us a little bit more
detail on back for blood's new pvp mode
swarm
thanks for having me i can't wait for
everyone to get their hands on this game
we're all really excited ah i can't wait
either
the good news is that you guys won't
have to wait too long
there's an open beta coming up on august
12th with an early access portion on
august 5th available to those who
pre-order
that's all for today but back for blood
still has a lot more to reveal in the
coming months so
stay tuned bye